all right Mike so we just saw heroes
reborn Gemini on PC from imperative
entertainment time puzzle fighting game
what you think about it
yeah so that's kind of combining combat
platforming and I guess somewhat puzzle
solving but basically yeah you can go
between two time periods and use that in
stealth sequences and just all-out
combat you can reverse bullets there
seems like it's open for experimentation
at least in so far as the demo I played
was so we have been talking about
quantum break a lot but this seems like
it's actually trying to do sort of new
things with time yeah seem to be much
more of a sandbox in Contra Break cuz I
remember when we first saw quantum break
the first trailer they showed I thought
it was gonna be more of an investigation
game and then later trailers we saw
they're just basically cutscenes where
as heroes reborn actually seems to be
mostly about investigation of these
scenes and the combat occurs you know
when you are for example in the demo
that we saw when you're trying to
basically chase somebody who was
kidnapped in another time and you're
warping between that time and this time
trying to figure what happened to them
and then having those like really fun
unreal physics base fights in between
yeah we're pretty much bouncing back and
forth between these two time periods one
was like kind of more modern and it's
just dilapidated facility but then you
just press a button and you go back to
it like several decades before that and
it's still you know a functioning
facility and you can kind of use this
during combat so you come into this room
and there's a bunch of guards and you
don't know how you're gonna take them
out so you can kind of peek through
these like tears almost and see where
the people are in the future time period
go back to the past and then come back
grab them pull them back you can kind of
separate them if you wanted to you can
isolate all of them in the past if you
wanted to you can use telekinesis that's
how you're picking these people up and
as long as you don't hold on them for
too long to kind of help us and this
also leads to these points where you can
kind of warp into the new time period
grab someone put them next to an
electrical box so they're just getting
shocked while everybody else kind of
watches escape back to the past and from
what I played it didn't seem like it was
too challenging I mean it was a power
fantasy in the sense that
I was the only one with power it seemed
like everybody else is kind of shooting
these maybe like 22 caliber guns that
didn't really hurt me that much I could
slow down time and stop the bullets and
reverse them back at the people you know
and then you start encountering like
harder guards that kind of have wrist
rockets and take a lot more damage and
have smaller weak spots on their backs
but we kind of found ourselves wishing
that they could chase you across the
time periods because it essentially as
long as you're not getting punched in
the face repeatedly it's a
get-out-of-jail-free card all I had to
do if I got in any trouble was press
like lb and I would go back to the past
or to the future where the guards
weren't so we were saying we would like
more puzzles where there are guards in
both time periods because even then
picking up a guard in the past warping
to the future with him and then
isolating them all in the future that's
still pretty compelling because then
you're just saying okay I'm gonna create
this safe space in case I need to back
out but from what we played there wasn't
really much of that so it just became
this oh my god I'm in trouble let's get
the food here I'm safe for a while I can
just take my time and do whatever I want
final thoughts I did enjoy the combat in
this game just because I like it
wouldn't developer is willing to give
people a set of tools and then risk
things going wrong in their game with
the physics like sandbox yeah I think
history if there's anything has taught
us in video games that licensed games
are not the safest bet and I think going
into it that was my expectation and
right now it's not doing a ton to
impress me although like you said I do
appreciate it's letting me improvise and
it's letting me experiment because it's
those freeform
emergency scenarios I'm really looking
forward to if they can kind of
capitalize on that but right now I just
guess time will tell because like you
said quantum break is gonna be the one
we want to go to if we want it's really
good story hopefully in this kind of you
know finely crafted narrative right now
heroes it's driving force to me is that
experimentation so I'm hoping that
justice becomes a thread throughout the
entire game
I gotta be honest rag dolling guards
throughout the demo we saw it never got
old
you